but the thing is I never played Hikaru
and I've seen
cinekaru Crush everybody else and even
in this tournament but I always thought
that I matched up decently with him but
then yeah at some point like he was
playing a lot faster than I was and he
was playing much better seeing all kinds
of tactics and that was a massive
reality check for me I was uh at that
point I was thinking oh okay so he's
just that much better than I am
um uh I was like yeah fair enough uh
this guy's just a beast and uh yeah what
I just want to say is I'm I'm extremely
I'm extremely impressed I mean I always
knew that he was that he was good I
always thought that he was somewhat
better than I was at bullet but that he
was like this much better I didn't
didn't realize and yeah it's uh it's
insanely impressive